Let's go next to our caller from the seven
seven five area code seven seven, five.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Oh, Hey David.
My name is Emmanuel.
I'm calling from Reno, Nevada.
Hey, how are you?
Oh, fine.
My family and I are huge fans.
We watch you pretty much every day, so I appreciate
you, uh, giving us a chance to call in.
My pleasure.
Uh, my question is, uh, and here in Nevada,
if you get committed, uh, if you commit a
crime and you're charged with a crime, um,
if, if they find that you're addicted to some
type of drugs, they have a program called
drug court where if you complete the program,
you know, you pretty much, those charges get
dropped.
Do you think that if Trump does eventually
get charged, they will bring up his obvious,
you know, narcotic or
no, listen, uh, I, I love the question and
I actually, I, I'm guessing that this only
applies to certain crimes, right?
Like if you murder someone and you say, I'm
on drugs, they don't say, Hey, you can do
a drug program and we won't indict you for
murder.
Right.
It doesn't work that way.
Correct.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's only a certain,
probably the only crime that it wouldn't apply
to, but pretty much anything else in our,
in our state as well as there's other States
that have similar programs.
You're saying that in Nevada, if you're accused
of, uh, violently raping someone, but you
say, I was high at the time, they will say,
go to a drug program and you don't get indicted.
That doesn't sound right.
It does.
It does sound kind of crazy, but unfortunately
that's pretty much how it is.
You can run someone over if you say, I was,
you know, on addicted to drugs.
Okay.
No, but hold on a second.
More lenient.
The car accident, the vehicular manslaughter.
That's a bigger issue and there's a lot of
research about how if you wanted to murder
someone, one of the most, one of the safest
ways to do it is to run them over in what
looks like a car accident.
That's a very specific one, but in any case,
I don't know exactly what crimes fall under
this or don't.
It doesn't really matter.
Your question about if Trump gets indicted
after being out of office, could he cite a
drug problem as the reason why you did it?
Trump is not going to get indicted once he
gets out of office and I keep, this is something
I keep coming back to.
The 25th amendment won't remove Trump.
The Mueller was never going to remove Trump.
Impeachment is not going to remove Trump.
There's one opportunity to remove Trump earlier
than he otherwise might be removed, which
is to vote him out in November rather than
give them a second term.
I think thinking about anything other than
getting out the vote in November is, is maybe
theoretically interesting, but I don't know
that we would want to put too much time into
it because it's not going to happen.
Right.
Well how about this, this isn't my last question
Dave.
I know you've got a lot more people.
How come do you, why do you think sometimes
the media hasn't really connected the dots
between, uh, Russia's interest in Ukraine
and why Trump has such a, you know, a foothold,
you know, and what he's trying to do and Ukraine
isn't an obvious that whatever he's doing
in Ukraine is most likely benefiting Russia.
He's probably working for Russia.
Well, it, you have to accept some premises
that a lot of people right now reject in order
that analysis makes sense.
If you accept some of the premises about the
relationship between Russia and the United
States and two to counter what you're saying
that nobody's mentioning it.
I have seen some mentions of that, but very
quickly they're kind of shouted down as, you
know, hoaxers a Russia conspiracy theorists
or whatever.
So it often doesn't really get the full conversation
it might deserve.
Uh, sad.
Well that makes sense.
You pretty much answered everything I had
in mind, David, and, uh, again, we appreciate,
uh, your, your work and,
all right.
Thank you so much Emmanuel.
Say hi to everybody over there.
Appreciate the support of your family.
And I hope to hear from you again.